I found in the last year I decided I
wanted to connect with people more by
showing them who I really was instead of
consistently going after the audience as
an insult comic I still do insult comedy
I love it but I'd been asked for so many
years hey what's the deal with the
weight loss what's the deal with your
personal life what's the deal with the
divorce what's the deal with like these
suppose it like spiritual retreats you
go on because I'll throw a little things
out about it and I go people really want
to know what makes us tick people like
to know about our struggles too so I've
decided to talk a lot more about those
things and in my new special and
probably my specials from now on I'm
just going to talk more about what I've
been through as far as an evolution in
the last few years and also show people
that they're not alone in their
struggles too because I think that's
super powerful is going I struggled for
32 years with my weight and I had no
other choice but to get this surgery and
get weight loss you know that way that
extreme so I think people go oh I'm not
alone I'm not the only one and that
feels good so that's how I'm challenging
myself lately
and I think that's enough of a challenge
because it's like while really exposing
what's wrong with me ever since I lost
the weight every interviewer starts with
oh my god you must love the way you look
let me tell you something I'm 53 freakin
years old
in clothes I'm clearly ridiculously hot
because I am a tasty piece
however out of clothes just like the
rest of you messes over 40 I am freakin
horrifying
I found that ever since I decided to
open up a little more and show people
who I am without being heavy handed and
without sort of banging a message home
of like hey I'm gonna help you through
my struggles just by being funny about
them and bring them to light I think
it's not a coincidence that the minute I
started doing that I started getting
standing ovations again I had stopped
getting standing out
- years ago and I was like wonder why I
like I'm still super funny but I think
people were like okay you know that's
cool we love Lisa that's fine but
there's something about opening up a
little without them even kind of
tangibly being able to figure out how
but they started just jumping up at the
like revelations and I go okay this is
working for them it's working for me and
it makes me feel like I have a purpose
more as a human being so I kind of love
that so I think it's really resonating I
feel I learned honesty from Howard Stern
Howard Stern was always even in the old
days out there talking honestly about
his life honestly about you know his
small penis size or whatever he makes
fun of about himself his looks etc and I
just go I'm just gonna be honest about
what I hate about myself I'm gonna be
honest about my foils and how idiotic I
can be and I think that's really
important for me as a comic I don't know
if it's necessarily important for all
comics but it adds a layer that I think
the audience resonates with you and says
oh I want to get to know them better oh
I want to hang out with them after you
know I want to leave a show having the
audience saying oh she's the type of
person I could be friends with so that's
kind of a nice goal to have you know I'd
never be friends with those losers I
mean come on they're paying to see me
but I mean I want to just have that
feeling of well we're all on the same
page
you